What are you doing?
Waaaaaah!
Waaaaaaaaaah!
Waaaaaah! Welcome!
Snipped at some pies.
Welcome to the stream.
Waaag!
Guess what?
I almost missed stream because I decided to take a nap.
I decided to take a nap.
And I slept through the three alarms that I set up.
So I guess everyone was just really tired.
Anyways, welcome to the stream.
Today we're playing a game called Difficult Game About Climbing.
Why can this man not use his legs?
I don't know.
But we're playing.
Which arm do I release this arm?
Yeah.
Eee!
Oh!
Waaag!
Eee!
Ah!
Yeah!
Eee!
Yeah.
Okay.
We're gaming.
We're...
Wee.
Move your hand over here.
Thank you.
Wee!
Wee game!
Wee game it!
Yeah!
Game!
Ugh!
Yeah!
I'm so good at this!
Ah-ha-ha!
Ah-ha!
Ah!
Eee!
Eh?
Ah...
Hi.
It's really high.
Do it.
Eee!
Can I?
Okay!
Eh?
Eee!
Is this safe?
Is it safe over here?
Eee!
It was not safe at all!
Okay, maybe...
Maybe...
No.
Maybe over here is safer.
Woo!
Eee!
Ah-ha-ha!
Okay, I got it!
I got it!
I got it, Senpai!
Come on, Mouse.
Don't...
Don't mess with me!
Don't mess with me yet!
Yeah!
See?
Okay!
Mister!
Your hands!
Woo!
Tei!
Yeah!
We got it!
Uh...
Stay.
Maybe if I pull up a little bit more?
Yeah.
Uh...
Eh.
Hmm.
Ooh!
Flippery.
Huh!
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho!
Yeah!
Baby!
Ah!
Come on!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, no, I have to get the top top!
Come on!
Come on, grippers!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Okay, maybe that's not a good idea.
Go here.
Yeah.
Woo!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Is this man, Diogenes?
This philosopher that lives in a pot
and pees on people?
Ah!
Woo!
I thought I had it.
Yeah!
Don't fucking do that to me, man!
Behold, Kohai!
A man!
That had to change his definition.
Who was that?
That had to change the definition of a man?
Yeah.
Plato, yeah.
Ooh.
Gamer.
Game.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah!
Eh?
That's...
That's the way.
Point it down.
Oh!
Ah!
I made it!
Yeah.
Oh!
I'm not gonna lie.
I have no idea...
which way to go.
Am I going down?
Still, or was I supposed to go up?
Up?
Don't tell me it's this one!
Yeah.
Hmm.
Can I do it?
I don't know if I can do it.
Senpai, I don't know if I can do it!
Hmm.
I'm so scared!
What if this sign actually does mean death, Senpai?
Senpai!
Ah!
Oi!
Eh!
My Senpais are...
jerks, and I'm...
never...
leaving them...
ever...
again!
Fuck!
Don't worry, I'm speeding this.
Yeah.
Man!
He just fucking swam through the lives!
Dwing!
I said the stream was going to be loud, Senpai!
Why didn't you believe me when I said that?
Come on.
Yeah.
Ha!
No!
Use your...
use your hands!
Use your hands!
Yeah!
Hands!
Safe.
Safeful.
Hands are getting...
Oh no, I'm gripping the mouse so hard, Senpai!
My hands!
Are crapping!
It's like...
holding scissors.
Suffer in the not right way.
Gaming.
Come on.
Oh no!
You're slipping!
How did I do this again?
I was such a gamer earlier.
Yeah.
I should have some of it.
Eat.
Eat!
Give me a second.
Ah!
My hand!
Okay.
Senpai, my hands are...
small.
This mouse is big!
Okay?
Do you see my dilemma there?
Huh.
You could just reach it just fine last time.
What?
So I have to have like this internal grip on him.
You reached it fine last time.
I can hold it on the keyboard as well.
Hold on.
I can pull up.
Huh.
Oh!
Ah!
Alright.
Ugh.
Wait.
Go Serenities here!
I love Serenity!
Cosmica!
Okay.
Come on.
Come on!
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
Haha!
Yeah!
Can I borrow...
Oh yeah!
Stop there!
Don't you fall!
This better not break like twice, right?
It just...
It's just there to spook me, right?
Right, Senpai?
Yeah.
Alright.
Okay, leap of fate.
Hey.
Wait.
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Senpai!
I got a bone to pick with you!
Haha!
How can I trust...
Oh, there has to be an easier way, right?
Uh...
I didn't realize he slipped.
Why are you like this, Mr. Oh?
Why are you like this?
I'm so mad!
Grab.
I'm just wondering if I can reach up there.
Hold on.
Let me just...
Okay.
Good.
Ehhh...
allergen?
Oh.
Okay.
It seems too high.
Yeah, you know what, we're not gonna do it, we're not gonna risk it, uh-oh, we're not
gonna risk that, nope, nope, I'm wondering, instead of going in and around, I can somehow
just get over there.
Probably not.
Boogie.
That's it, what's on the other side?
What's on the other side?
Let's just check it out.
Let's just check out what's on the other side.
Literally nothing.
The way he swam was so funny though.
Okay, come on.
And nothing, okay.
What?
He swam straight down?
No.
Can he drown?
No, but I booted up the game a little bit earlier and he can drift away.
Did you know he can drift away in the water?
He can drift away in the water, what the heck, right?
That was my mistake, by the way.
Stay.
Yeah.
Yeah, you got it.
Yeah, we got this.
Yeah.
What?
Stay, stay, stay.
I trust you.
I trust you, Mr. Bald Naked Man, sir.
Please don't, don't break this trust.
Yeah.
This bald man has a name.
Apparently his diogenes, apparently.
But I know that man doesn't shave, so.
Ooh, that was kind of dangerous.
Stay, stay, stay, stay.
Oh, what, okay.
How many pull-ups can you do, Marcy?
Zero.
Are you sure it's supposed to be this way, Senpai?
It's kind of dangerous.
Oh, that's where it falls, too.
Good to know.
Use your, your, your yowly hands.
Ow.
Yowly hands usually slip rate.
Yeah, with that amount of lube they use.
Yeah.
Yep.
I can't get in the tub, Senpai.
I have no water today.
Apparently the water's going to turn on tomorrow, maybe.
I forgot to grip.
Maybe, I don't know, like, there could be lots of things that happen, right?
Yeah.
I don't know why I decided to climb on this thing when it's literally so easy to reach this.
I was so stupid.
What happened to your water?
Some emergency water line thing.
Water thing, so they're like, okay, we got to, like, check for, like, stuff, and I was like, okay.
No shower, like, no water at all, so I'm like, okay.
I've got, like, a ton of water because Papa has just a habit of boiling water and putting them into, like, bottles, so we just have lots.
Interesting, so when was the last time you showered?
Some questions are left to the imagination, yeah?
Did you want the truth?
Some plays?
You wanted the truth?
I haven't showered since debut.
Here.
Today was my shower day, and then, well, turns out I'm destined to be stinky today.
I haven't showered for debut because I was like, okay, I'm really stressed, so I'm going to shower for debut, and then I've been preparing a lot of stuff for Senpai, so I haven't had time.
And today I was like, oh, well, I don't have a lot of stuff to prepare today, so I'm just going to have a shower today.
The water, the electrician gas and water place was like, blur away your water!
And I was like, oh, great.
Oh, come on.
Why am I so bad at this suddenly?
Thank you for the tip!
Thank you for the...
I can't read how much that was. Thank you for the tip, Mr. Tony.
I don't think I smell too badly.
Maybe today I do.
Why is this area so much harder than it was like three minutes ago?
Like, I don't think... Okay, okay. Senpai, you're always like, oh, you're so stinky, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But Senpai...
I don't sweat that much.
Not that much. I do sweat, but like, I don't sweat that much.
Oh, come on.
That's what they all say! Who's all? Who's they? Who's they? What the fuck? Senpai, who is they?
Who the fuck is they?
Mars! Cut off his testicles!
I can't believe my Senpais would cheat on me like this.
I can't believe it. The entire time. I've done this for all of you guys. Look at me. I'm struggling. I'm struggling in this game.
For you, Senpai! And then what's the thing I get? Your dirty fucking cheating ass hole!
I don't smell.
Okay. I don't smell that much.
In fact, science says that it should be, you know, with the person you love, the sweat smells like pheromones, so it should smell like flowers.
Okay.
I'm so mad! I got distracted. I got so angry.
Oh, are you sweating? A little bit.
I got distracted and angry. I was mad and angry and mad and pissed!
Anyways, I don't sweat. So, see, sweat that much. So, only once in a while does my pits stink, and you're going to be so shocked about this Senpai.
For some reason, my feet don't sweat, and I don't know why.
Are they okay? I don't know. Maybe it's just naturally dry.
Here is the areas that I do sweat a little bit more than usual.
I sweat more around my neck.
And I sweat more around my lower back.
But yeah, it's mostly my neck.
Like the back of my neck gets really sweaty.
My pits can get sweaty.
And, oh yeah, it's mostly my neck. I always have to apply deodorant there.
Your hair long or short?
Senpai, do you have eyes? It's long.
Like you seem bad to me. Are we looking at the same characters? I'm right here Senpai! You know what the scissors in the hair? Hello? Did you forget what I looked like? Are you cheating? Are you such a cheating cheater that you forgot what I looked like?
I don't know what I looked like.
I was hoping I could get that to work.
I was going to say something bad, but I remember that YouTube will hate bad words.
Are you going to say the C word? No! I was going to say the S word.
Yeah, new tech. New tech found.
Oh, Azura! Thank you for the raid! Azura! Azura! Azura!
Okay, I saw Senpai say I should be more up here. That I have bigger swing, right?
Welcome Raiders! Welcome to the stream! We are playing a very difficult game, a climbing game.
You'll hear lots of screams from me.
I don't know Senpai, this seems a little far. Are you sure this is where I should be? Like here, maybe here? This looks safer.
I don't know. Okay, maybe I should be up more.
Are you here? Okay.
Azura, you're going to cramp your hand! Don't do this!
Oh, come on. Fine, just use- there you go.
Efficiency. I take it back.
I take it back when I said.
Oh, man, I'm so not a gamer. You know, at the beginning of the game, where I was like, yeah, I'm gaming. I'm gaming, bros. I'm gaming Senpai. That was a lie.
Okay, I was in denial of my true strength. You know, I thought I had the ability, but turns out my ability that I had was a lie and that I was strongly overcompensating for my skills.
I thought I was a gamer. I thought I was. You know what? I lied. I lied. I'm not a gamer at all. You guys can't punish me for this.
My Senpais can't punish me for not being able to game, okay? Look at me. Look at me. This is because my hands are sweaty. Yeah, it's totally because my hands are sweaty.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
So does his legs not work now? This man's leg just doesn't work. All we can do is rely on these arms that seem to have the power of, of like a thousand who's like, who's able to hold on for, for dear life for such a long time.
Yeah.
Ah.
Just grab on, man.
Well, yeah. Hiya.
Hiya. Hiya. Hiya. Hiya.
esperar
Yeah.
Meow.
Hi. Hi.
No, I want to be higher, right?
Maybe a bit higher?
Oh, maybe I should be more to the edge.
Oh, he slips.
I forgot he slips.
I got spooked.
Stop counting my falls!
I don't need to know the amount of times I fail. I just need to know the amount of times I win.
I know this is the beginning.
Stop bullying me!
Got it.
There we go.
It's fun! Slippery! Slippery!
Hmm.
Yeah!
This man just goes, brrr, cold.
Oh, brrr.
This is a mean game. This is a rain game. I know it's a rain game. My man does not feel that great.
A hard but not impossible game is what they said. And I wanted to show off to Senpai that I could probably do it.
Right now I'm starting to question my life choices.
Senpai's must be better gamers than me.
Shut up, Amy!
Easy. Easy your way.
I don't like that area. That area sucks. You know what? That sucks. That sucks balls. Okay?
I can't believe I fell at that part.
Eh, eh, wah, wah, wah. Fuck you. Fuck this bullshit.
No.
Hmm.
Hmm. Focus. Laser focus.
Laser focus.
Hmm.
Maybe I need my hand like here.
Nyeh.
Shut up. Shut up Senpai.
Okay, one handed gameplay.
And a drink tea.
What do you think it is? By the way, it's an apple cinnamon. Apple cinnamon tea.
Oh yeah.
Maybe I should have been here.
Just need to be brave.
I'm not brave.
Give me a second.
Nyeh.
Senpai, you're not tired of me, right? You still love me, right? Even though I'm a bad gamer?
I don't even know how physics work.
There's some games I'm good at you. I bet.
Like rock, paper, scissors maybe?
Visual novels are like, it's gameplay but it's not like gameplay, you know?
I can guess I'm okay at detective games and puzzle games, sort of.
Nyeh.
Seriously, can I get these arms? How does this man not just buff in the arms?
Nessie. Oh yeah.
Was it here? Or did I need to go down here? I can't remember.
Nyeh.
Hold on, I need to position this. That didn't count as a fall, I caught my way down.
Okay, maybe that one did.
Senpai, this hurts my hand too much. I don't know if I should play with a controller or not.
Because this hurts my hand a lot. I don't know if it's gonna work.
This is kind of harder.
This is less precise.
Just that my hand really hurt with the mouse. That's a little hard. I'll see what we can do.
He's dangling. This is harder.
It doesn't hurt my hand as much. This is gonna be a new learning curve.
A new learning curve, but it doesn't hurt my hand as much. Thank you for the dollar you do a day in white.
Oh gosh, this is so hard to control for the controller. I know it's technically easier on mouse, but...
Mercy's hand's hurt.
I don't know if I should play with a controller or not.
This is so hard to control the hands. Look how much more flingy he is.
Oh no!
I don't know if I should play with a controller or not.
No, no, no, I have no idea.
Learning the controller is so hard.
At least less hand pain, yeah. Oh my goodness.
Such a learning curve. I should definitely invest in a smaller mouse. What the heck? Why did I buy such a big, enormous thing?
I don't know why I did that. What mouse? It's a HyperX. I bought it because it was pink. It actually kind of sucks, because it always disconnects.
Oh, come on.
Oh no!
Oh, it's not a wireless mouse. The mouse I got is a wired mouse. It disconnects all the time and I always have to go to the back of the PC and grab it because it sucks.
Oh, come on.
This man swings too much.
Let's try this part with the mouse instead.
Oh, come on.
Maybe try a different USB port. All my USB ports are taken, so there's only one place left for it.
When I had my other mouse... I'm going back to mouse style. I'm sorry. It was just too hard.
When I had my other mouse, it worked just fine. Same ports, everything. It's just this HyperX1 freaking sucks.
Oh, come on.
Thank you for the 420 King Chucky.
This is my Zatsu. Sorry, I'm just like super focused. Hyper, hyper, hyper focused.
I'm going back to the mouse. It hurts me, but I can control it better.
That's it. I'm going to put a new mouse on my list. I was like, yeah, I wanted to be pink. I wanted it to be pink and cute and adorable so it can match all the rest of my stuff.
Oh, it sucks. Oh, whatever. I feel like...
Can I grab with Q? Like this? I guess this works.
Okay, well, this works. I just have to remember which key is which.
I have to claw it. So that's good. Thank you.
Okay.
Why is this getting harder? Maybe it's because I'm getting more frustrated.
My favorite color is purple. I'm trying to get stuff to match purple and white, right? I guess aesthetics is important, in my opinion. I feel like if things around me are the colors that make me happy and I can be happy.
That's why I have all my dog cages to be super cute and pink and adorable. I painted them all cute colors.
Maybe here?
Are you not allowed to customize? You know how I said I like color coordination senpai? I like all my things to be color coordinated. Understood?
Yeah.
Just got to deal with the carpal tunnel.
Bitch.
Yeah.
Senpai, this part is hard. And this is the beginning.
I want to be a gamer, but I suck at gaming.
Son of a slut!
I'm sorry for using bad words.
Don't worry.
Don't worry. I soundproofed everything. So, senpai. The neighbors won't normally hear me. Normally.
I don't mind a little back seating, but I really don't know where to go how to get to this part.
Do I swing here?
Do I swing with both arms? Like this? This?
Hmm. Kind of scary.
Do-do-do.
I don't know.
You slipped down more. Maybe I'm just stupid?
Instead of flipping, you mean like, hold on. Maybe you're on to something, senpai.
No, no, no, no!
I'm not a gamer. That's it. I relinquish that title for someone more worthy of such a title.
I'm not a gamer.
Yep.
Okay.
Now do the same as before, but let go slightly early so your body won't flip.
Why does everyone get stuck at the same part every time? Well, maybe that part is hard, senpai.
At this point, I'm not even watching it anymore. I'm just like, okay, well, this time I've already got a pattern sort of how to like do this.
Just this one part. One part. It gets harder. I know. But this one part, I just want to get past it. I just want to get past this one part.
It's deft doable, but like maybe I just don't know the trick to it, you know?
We never lose, we never give up. This is what... This is what persistence is. Oh, shit. Ah, fuck.
Tenacity, persistence. I don't know what other words there are. I don't have a thesaurus on me.
Is it possible to head first instead of swinging? Honestly, I have no idea.
Like, I would love to... I feel like I'm gonna flip, so I just... I don't know. I don't know, senpai. I don't know.
That one goes back down to the beginning.
I want to get closer but I'm also kind of worried that I won't be able to swing far enough.
Hmm?
I just made him do a weird shimmy! I just made him do the Stingin' Nansen!
Attarashi Gakkou!
Otona Blue.
Hup.
Alright.
Hmm. This part's hard. I'm... I don't know. Maybe I need to watch a video of someone doing it?
But I feel like that's cheating. I feel like that's cheating. And I'm not a cheater. I'm a quitter, but not a cheater!
I'm like, you guys! And I'm like, senpai's! Cheater, cheating.
Oh, shit.
Hmm.
Oh.
Hup.
I don't know which rock it is that I should... Like, I can't tell if I should be, like, trying this rock or this rock.
Buh!
Hup.
Hup!
He didn't hold on.
Hup.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I almost had it and then I failed.
I want such a hard area. I don't know why it's such a hard area.
I know why.
Game Devs Evil.
Why did I decide to play this game?
How many hours in? I'm nearly two hours in and I suck!
I recognize my weaknesses, Senpai. Do you recognize your weaknesses?
My weakness includes...
My weakness includes impatience!
But at the same time, I'm a little stubborn.
Hup.
There we go.
I'm your greatest weakness, Senpai!
I think it was here.
So, uh, I didn't get it.
I didn't get it.
I'm back!
Did Mercy make it to the top?
No, we're back at the bottom, and now, well, we're in the bottom still.
Oh, he always slips there.
I intercept back.
We got this.
Yeah, we got this.
We still winning.
We're in the grind mindset.
Um, every day your life is, uh, uh, is a power tool made to rock?
I don't fucking know.
Oh, something about Northern Lion.
I mean, MC's bald, yeah.
Sometimes I look at life and I go, what would, what would this bald man Northern Lion would
say?
And I force it on to other people.
Something involving hammers, probably, and then I start getting angry and then maybe
I'll use the hammers on Senpai.
Is it this?
I can't remember which rock it was.
Was it this rock?
Which rock did I vibe with Senpai?
I couldn't remember which rock I vibe with.
This one?
Is it this rock that I vibe with?
This one right here on the little corner, this little sliver?
Or did I go the one up?
No, go up.
Okay.
This was the one that I, I vibe with.
Bottom of the middle rock.
Was it this bottom of the middle rock that I vibe with?
This bottom.
And I'm not talking about, like, you know, a bit higher.
What about here was the vibe?
Alright.
That was not the vibe.
Me and you?
Well, I'm at the bottom here.
Good check failed.
Every time.
I just don't like it.
It doesn't mesh with my karma.
It just doesn't mesh with my karma Senpai.
That area is full of negative energy.
Really a Scorpio.
I don't know what else they say.
Oh man.
What if I get a rock?
I have like some, some, some like, some like rocks.
And then what if I get a rock and then I pray to that rock and then be like, yes, let's
meditate on this rock so we can make this jump.
I swung.
Was it not hard?
Air guitar.
I don't know what I forgot what guitar sounds like because I don't really listen to music.
So in my mind, when you said like, oh, you air guitar down, I was like, air banjo, it's
dead.
It's like I'm in here or something.
Oh, unless we're talking about the guitar, is it a guitar?
I've been watching Yu Yu Hakusho.
So I have Yu Yu Hakusho brain rot right now.
So the sound effect.
Something happens.
Do you remember Senpai?
Right now I'm on the arc where the arc following what's his face's plan to open the kick kai
barrier kick kai means barrier.
Yeah.
Right now we have.
Oh my gosh.
Close your ears.
Oh, close your ears right now.
Currently demon guy was like, I'm hungry, I can't take it anymore.
And that's where I'm at.
That's it.
That's the part I'm at.
Oh, I'm still scared Senpai.
I'm still scared.
I don't actually remember how I did it.
I don't remember how I did it.
Just do it.
Give me a second, let me test something.
Okay, I definitely swing back if I let go there.
I have to let go as I'm swinging.
Senpai!
We did it!
Wow!
Huh, now I'm stuck.
We live here now.
I'm sweating from my neck.
I can feel the sweat dripping down my neck right now.
This is where we live now.
We're home now.
This is our rock.
This is where we live now.
That's all that mattered.
We peaked once.
I was so close Senpai.
I was so close.
I didn't know I was slip and slide right there.
My slip and slide days.
I assume you're already familiar with getting over it.
Yeah, and guess what?
I got over it.
Actually, I didn't get over it.
I got to the one area with all the curls and then I just gave up there.
I can't believe there was a slide there.
I was like, okay, just swing and then I...
I was like, okay, well, grab onto that area.
It'll be fine.
Slip and slide, baby.
Did you get to the anvil?
I think I got to the anvil.
I'm not sure.
I made it to peak and then I fell off.
That's how it goes, right?
I fell off, literally.
We can peak again.
I gave up.
I can't believe you would have that vocabulary in you, Mercy Modest.
Well, guess what?
I do.
I'm a quitter, but not a cheater.
Except for when cheating feels good in games.
Do you know Black Clover?
Does anyone know Black Clover?
I'm going to give you a spoiler.
When Asta, they were cheating in this tournament thing
and then Asta was like, you weren't cheating?
Why didn't you tell me I wanted to cheat, too?
And I felt that.
No, we're not cheating that way.
We're talking about cheating in games, you know?
The only cheaters I know is you, Senpai.
That's why you have to cut off your fingers sometimes.
Oh my gosh, do not make this about NTR.
It's like you guys have brain rot.
It's like some Senpais have brain rot for NTR
and that's all they can think about.
You know what NTR I think about?
New times, Romans.
I'm just saying.
I don't want questions about that anymore.
I don't want questions about that.
I want people to assume anything.
Why? Because I only love my Senpais.
New times, Romans, good.
It's a good font.
I promise Senpais that I only have Senpai in my heart.
And maybe Serenity, sorry.
Serenity in my gym mate, sorry.
See the power of my gen mates in Serenity.
Serenity in my gym mate.
I feel like...
Can we get higher before?
I slept.
I slept. That was scary.
By the power of Serenity and my gen mates Azra, Imi, Isi, Shibi, Strony.
I will make it.
Oh no, my mouse is so sweaty.
My hands are making me sweat.
I did it, I did it, I did it.
My gamer license has been reinstated.
I made progress but now my hands are really sweaty.
I'm super sweaty now.
I might be a real gamer because of how sweaty I am.
I think I just flowed here for a little bit.
Look at my little oasis.
Yeah.
Yeah, my little oasis with my little waterfall.
I got these beautiful leaves.
This wonderful ambience.
Do you have any gamer gloves?
No.
We live here now.
Why would we want to go more?
I don't normally game this hard.
Oh, the carpal tunnel though.
I feel it in my fingies.
I really feel it.
It's so sore now.
Can I save here?
Am I allowed to save or does it start at the beginning again?
I don't know.
Carpal tunnel.
I'm so sweaty now.
My neck feels like a waterfall.
Where is the bath water?
My bath is kind of small.
How do we get past here?
All of the roots, just be careful.
This is kind of scary.
These roots?
I don't feel safe out of my oasis.
I'm going back to my oasis.
I don't feel safe outside of my oasis.
That area was so dark.
I was like, this is an area that's dangerous.
We live here now.
This is where we live.
This oasis probably has fish, right?
We'll fish together some pie.
We can eat the leaves.
These are good nutritious leaves.
You can probably be free in this area without your cages.
Where else would you go?
Why would you leave my oasis?
You can always go down.
I worked really hard to get here.
I'm going back to my oasis.
This is where I live now.
We all live here.
We collect berries and go collecting berries.
This area looks dangerous.
I'm kind of scared of it.
How's the wi-fi here? I don't know. Check it.
I think it's good.
We live here now.
Do I have to go for bush to bush?
How do I get bush to bush?
Maybe this bush and then go to that bush.
Maybe that bush and we swing.
I was already at that bush.
Is that the bush I was supposed to go to?
I don't know if I can reach that high.
I'm stuck here.
We live here forever.
Why do we want to move anyways?
What is the climb?
No!
Senpai! Senpai! Senpai!
Senpai!
Shit!
Is it just me or are these not easy to reach?
Is this going to break?
I'm stuck here.
Senpai! Senpai! Senpai!
Senpai, I'm a gamer!
This looks dangerous.
I don't think I'm ready for this yet.
Water! Water safe! Water!
This is scary Senpai!
This part is a part where everybody drops, don't they?
Oh god.
I lost my home!
Look, he just floats.
Senpai, we're homeless again!
Now the sea only tastes like salt.
Where is that my tears?
We live here now.
That was it.
I knew it.
That sign was dangerous and I knew it and we all knew it.
I'm too tired for this now.
We rage quit, yeah.
Yeah, we rage.
We rage quit.
We live in a society.
We live in a society where bald men who can't use their legs
can't even find a home.
The housing market is terrible.
I made it to peak.
I made it to our little oasis.
I went past our little oasis because I wanted more.
I should have just been happy with what I had.
I just became so greedy.
We should have just lived in the oasis.
We were homeowners.
I don't know how long we were homeowners, but I wanted more.
The Home Owners Association.
I wanted to be the president of the Home Owners Association.
And then we just, we failed.
We failed.
I'm so sad.
So sad, Senpai.
But what did we learn from that?
We learned that the power of friendship is the most powerful thing.
We wanted a house in this economy.
Heck, I was even, heck, I was even, I was even going to pay my mortgage.
My mortgage with the climb.
Are we only friends to Yuka?
I know.
My Senpais are in a loving relationship with me.
My friendship is with my girls.
Girls.
Well, thank you.
Set up for the 420.
I really appreciate it.
You did your best.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
We have the down payment.
And then we have to pay the principal.
And then we have to fight the other homeowners.
We have to fight the businesses that want to convert the entire area into a BNB,
a BNB enterprise, an Airbnb enterprise.
Man, homeownership's rough.
Corporal.
Corporal's always coming in, gentrifying the place.
The homeowners association hates me.
They hate me because I wear an eye patch.
That's it, right?
Although that is my dream, though.
I really do want to own my own place.
So I can have more freedom.
They won't even let me.
The homeowners association won't even let me have pink curtains.
I don't know.
Is those fancy apartments and flats?
Do they have homeowners associations or whatever?
Where they're like, you can't have colorful curtains.
Because then it brings the property down.
Sacrilege, I know.
I want my pink curtains.
Actually, my curtains are kind of like an off-white,
but they're like sheer and they look very ethereal.
Like a wedding dress, you know?
Will there be a yard to play in?
I don't know.
I don't like, I don't really like taking care of yards.
I don't like mowing, you know?
I don't like mowing.
Tempies won't take care of the mowing.
Off-light, off-light is prettier, I think.
Look at my tempi.
Let's be real.
If I wore white, look at my skin tone.
I would be blinding you, right?
I would be blinding you.
Tempies will do the landscaping?
Okay.
I want a fruit tree then.
I want a fruit tree so we can pick...
I don't know.
What grows on trees?
Apples?
We can pick apples.
Apples in the...
What time do apples...
What time are apples?
That depends on the place, right?
What time are apples in season?
Speaking of...
I want to tell you guys something.
It's kind of dumb.
But I was at a store.
I was at a store and I overheard these girls talking.
We can pick them in the fall then.
We can pick the apples in the fall.
So I overheard these girls talking.
I think they're fairly young.
And they were talking about Animal Crossing.
And they were like,
Why aren't there any strawberry trees?
And I didn't have the heart to say
Strawberry girls on bushes.
I didn't have the heart to say it.
I was listening and I was like...
What am I...
That's the reason why I don't have it.
I didn't have the heart to say it.
I remember I used to own some little strawberry plants.
I don't think they grow on vines.
But they were definitely in these little...
I guess tiny bushes like a little patch.
Where you can just pick them up.
I remember Papa Mercy.
Papa Mercy.
Decided to give them away as a gift to someone.
And I was like,
Damn, no more cute strawberry picking.
I thought of some names for Mama and Papa.
But I feel like I would just say Mama and Papa.
I think it would be really interesting though.
What do you guys...
What does my sump ice think?
I thought of some names.
Like their real names.
Papa's name is Please and Mama's name is Forgiveness.
Please.
And forgiveness, please.
It's hard to remember.
What do you mean?
It's the last thing you say sometimes when you're about to die.
Or when you're caught cheating.
It was yes, forgiveness.
I don't know.
Maybe like forgive me.
But like forgiveness.
Like dearest for mommy.
Mommy dearest.
Was Papa Mama Senpai?
She can be a little possessive of them.
Yeah.
Yeah, please, plus forgiveness equals mercy.
I'm just going full meta right now.
It never dead Rckney again.
Please.
Please and forgive
For you sounds like sounds like I forgot
I forgot
I forgive
Ha ha ha ha ha
Maybe Mama and Papa Mercy would be good
Ha ha ha ha
Ha ha ha ha ha
Yeah, Mama and Papa would try explaining every time
Well, at least you guys get to know Mama and Papa's name
That means you're ready for when you can pop the question
and ask for their permission to marry their daughter, right?
Ha ha ha
So you're ready, but it's not time yet
Ha ha ha ha ha
Mama Mercy, Mama Modisse is too good to replace
Hmm, okay
We're thinking about marriage
Were you, were you not thinking about marriage?
Hello?
That won't be the right time
Well, we have to go on so many dates first
Then we have to get to know each other way more
And then, you know
You know
Ha ha ha ha ha ha
Ha ha ha ha
One thing at a time
So we can go on dates on the outside, of course
Unless you're trying to find help
No one will help you some pie
Only I will
This was a rock climbing date
This was us trying to find a home, okay?
This was us trying to find a home
Ha ha ha ha
This was us climbing
Climbing to find a home
To get a mortgage
To pay the principal
Get a down payment
Then we got kicked out by the homeowners association
Ha ha ha ha
I mean like
The basement's getting a little bit crowded, right?
Some, some senpais have to share cages
So for now, we're gonna have to have a homeless date
No, we're gonna just move back into the basement now
Ha ha ha ha
We're just gonna have to move back into the basement
Ugh
Sadge
Ha ha ha ha ha
Well
Tomorrow I get to pick out date outfits
For my senpais
Not my senpais
Oh, I'm so sorry
I have senpai brain rot right now
For my gen mates, my girls
That will be kind of like
You know, we're getting ready for our first date with everyone
Ha ha ha
What about a 5k twitter audio?
To be honest
Um
I grew so fast
I'm getting kind of scared
I think it's more eyes on me
So I'm getting a little bit more shy
I'm getting a little bit more shy
Ha ha ha ha
So because I'm getting a little bit more shy
I'm getting a little bit more nervous to post a new audio
So which is why I'm just like
Oh, I don't know
I wanna treat my senpais
But I feel like some people amongst
I'm gonna share an intimate moment
But like maybe someone's gonna be spying on my intimate moment
With my senpais
Ha ha ha
I guess
It might take a little bit
I said soon, but it might be more like later
It might be more like later
I'm too shy right now
I was honestly
You know, I went to bed and I was like
Okay, 3k
Yeah, that's doable
Cool, I knew senpais
And then
I woke up and I was like
Oh, it went up to 4k
I woke up because of the call
Call of
About like my water being turned off
And I was like, okay
And then I was like
I'll go back to bed
And then, you know, I'll do it later
And then I woke up
To 6k
So basically
Almost double
Double
Of what I like originally
Was like, oh
I know Shibi
Got grew really fast as well
I think I accidentally found
The algorithm
I accidentally found the algorithm
I didn't even realize
I just, I was like
Originally
At 2k
I was like, oh
There's some vtubers following me
I should probably remind
Remind my vtuber
The vtubers following me that like
You know, not to be surprised
If there's
There's something
A little suss
Suss on there, but
Yeah
Like honestly, I'm
I'm a little
Nervous
A little lot nervous
What about Strony?
Wait is Strony still streaming?
Yeah, the vtubers supporting me
Are pretty base
I was like, oh
They're really, oh
They're really cute
I wanna like
You know
Still maintain a knot
She wants to raid in
But not sure if you're ending soon
This might turn into a long, longer
Yap, I'm sorry
Yeah, she's fine
If she wants to raid in
This might turn into a like
Maybe another hour long
You know, yap
Strony's definitely built different
I thought I had a pretty
Strong, um
I thought I had a pretty strong stamina
But I think Strony has like a stronger stamina
I'm of course fine with
Going just
If Senpai's are okay with me being a little sweaty
Hahaha
If I'm a little sweaty
Sweaty's good, yeah
Strony did an 8 plus hour stream
3 days in a row
Strony's too powerful
Honestly
How long, how long was today?
It's like
It's like basically a new day
12 hours, wild honestly
Did she take breaks?
I hope she took breaks
Yeah, I want Strony to take
Lost a rest
Honestly, Strony works really hard
Especially for us
Hahaha
That's wild
I don't know if I have that stamina
Honestly, usually
People
People like save such long streams
For like, uh
What's the word?
Endurance, endurance streams?
She only literally ate once?
Somebody yell at my
Yell at Mame
Somebody yell at Mame to eat real food
I'm kind of like my
I'm kind of doing my limit
Of maybe like 4 hours, 5 hours max
Otherwise
I feel like
I feel like I'm going to overwork my mods
I feel like I'll overwork the mods
If that happens
Let's go
Oh, Strony
Strony, Strony
I love Strony
If Strony loves me
Then I love her
Welcome Raiders
Welcome to the stream
We lost our home
Hahaha
Reflings raid
Yay
Take it away, Mercy
Thank you, Strony
Please rest up and eat real food
Or well, eat real food later
I don't know
It's your choice
Hahaha
I'm pretty sure Mame
Mame is going to pass the heck out right now
Yeah, we lost our home
We lost our home, Reflings
We lost our home
I was in a nice oasis
I wanted more
Got kicked out by the Homeowners Association
Hahaha
Eat real food
Me with cheeky macas
And my tum-tum
Mercy, love
I go sleepy time
Okay, have good rest
Mame
Here's a kiss for you
I'll tuck you in
Hahaha
Hi
I actually had a craving for McDonald's last night
I actually went out
I drove to McDonald's last night
And
I didn't
I had a very specific craving
Which was I really wanted their
Nes-T
Their Nes-T drink
I really wanted their Nes-T drink
So I got myself like a large Nes-T
Hahaha
I don't know
I feel like the fountain drinks
At McDonald's taste different, right?
Hahaha
That's very specific
I had a craving for it
I had a really big craving for it
I was like, I need this right now
And there's one about like
Like a five minute drive away
And they have a 24 hour drive through
So I was like, can I please
Have a large fountain drink
Hahaha
So
That's what I wanted
Specifically
Hahaha
And they were like, that's it
And I said, yep, that's it
How much is it?
Paid the price
Parked in the parking lot
Took a few sips
Started dissociating
Wondered about life
Pried a little bit
Went back home
Kicked on my supplies
They were all sleeping nice
Hahaha
And I went to bed
Bounds Marvin
Ah, it happens sometimes
I'm in a little bit of a
I'm in a little bit of a downer mood
Not thing in per
Maybe it is something in particular
I think it's just
I don't know
I guess it's a bit of a
Imposter syndrome?
Yeah
I was feeling down because of the imposter syndrome
Hahaha
So then I was like, oh
You know, going through
Going through the motions
Like literally, I go through the motions
And then I get sad
You know, I should be happy with my growth
But I'm like a little scared of it
Hahaha
I'm a little scared of it because
I've never had so many eyes on me before
Hahaha
So now I get a little shy
I get really shy
And I'm like, oh
Should I think more about what I do?
Hahaha
Yeah, we did talk about the
Love reading how wrong the chat summary can be
Apparently chat is talking about wanting her to go live
And her talking about her hatred for
Homeowners Association and love for McDonald's
Well, we got the Homeowners Association
Things are afraid
Hahaha
It was a metaphor
Oh
Hahaha
It was a metaphor
We got to an oasis
In a difficult game about climbing
Hahaha
And then I wanted more
And then I got kicked out
Oh, some pie
Thank you for the $4 news
What's the word for the day?
What's the word of the day for English again?
Hmm, let me think
Dichotomy
Hahaha
Word of the day is dichotomy
Another D word
Hahaha
Maybe I just have like the D dictionary in my head
Here
Dichotomy
A division or contrast between two things
That are or are represented by being opposed
Or entirely different
An example would be a rigid dichotomy
Rigid dichotomy between science and mysticism
Hahaha
Dichotomy between the oasis
And the Homeowners Association
It makes sense
Hahaha
I have D on the brain
Maybe
Hahaha
I don't know
I just picked a word
I was like, I don't know
It sounds nice right now
Hahaha
I would
Oh
Are there people who are new here that wasn't here for the last three?
Mama and Papa Mercy
I tried to explain multiple times
Somehow got in their heads
That I'm teaching
I'm teaching kids English
Online
Hahaha
Yeah
So my supplies are
Are my students?
Oh yeah
I tried to explain multiple times
I was like, oh yeah
You know I'm doing streaming
And they were like
Uh huh
And I said yeah
I'm doing streaming
And I like play games
And you know I make audios
And you know it's like
It's like I don't know
Like video on demand
But like uh me
And I'm talking to people
And they're like
Oh
You're teaching kids English
Okay
Hahaha
And then I was like
Why did you get that in your head?
They're like oh my gosh sweetie
You're doing such a good job
I always knew you all
You had the makings of being a teacher
And I just couldn't
I couldn't
I couldn't say no
I was like oh
I can't explain this
I mean mama
Mama and papa are the people
That go up to me and go
Sweetie
Netflix isn't working
Can you tell them to make it work again?
Hahaha
From call hi to sensei
So yeah
If anyone asks
Do they really know what I'm doing?
Not really
I'm sorry if this already been said
But your gen mates
I think I see is missing
Huh?
In my
In my description
I'll hit manai san for that
Hahaha
I'll hit manager for that
Would you say you have old parents
Or just super innocent?
Maybe a bit amicable
Umm
They're very
They were very strict with me
But like suddenly
I got like
They're like you're an adult now
You have so much
So much
Hahaha
Where was it?
Is it in the description?
Is the description
Doesn't have icy?
Manager fix that
Hahaha
Yeah manager
Get your ass moving
What the fuck
Why does that 20% go?
Hahaha
Okay
Manai
Manai can get on it
Hahaha
I always bully manager
But I do respect manager
Manager is what
Rains us in
Hahaha
Manager is what rains us in
So we can be free
Hahaha
To a certain extent
It's manager Senpai
Or no manager is manager
Discussing sounds
Manager is manager
Hahaha
Senpai on the other hand
I love Senpai
Ironically I think they copy and pasted
Icy's description
So Icy was missing from the list of gen mates
That's probably why
Efficiency comes at the cost
And the cost is
You know some details
Would you love us even if we were a worm?
Yes of course
You'll be the cutest worm ever
Hahaha
Thank you
By the two dollary dudes
Teach me some pie
What am I teaching?
More words?
Hahaha
Can I be a gummy worm?
Yeah gummy worm is natural cage habitat
Hahaha
It's probably it
Efficiency
Efficiency sometimes leads to
Missing details
At least you all caught it
Thank you for catching it
I always get ready for stream
Mostly the whole day is
Um
Well let's see what my schedule is
Kind of like my schedule is
Like planning the day stream
Mm-hmm
And then
Um catching up on chores
And things
Uh
On Twitter or promotional stuff
Planning the following weeks
And
Organize and collapse
It's a lot
Oh yeah and then I have to do my audios as well
So
It might seem like they're small tasks
But they can take quite a long time
Canonically
How many arms, fingers and toes do you have?
How many times did you cheat?
Hahaha
Do senpai scroll them back
For you to cut them again?
I might ask
Me to like
Resurrect senpai
So I can just kill senpai again
In Minecraft
Hahaha
Zero if you hit zero
Then you have all of your limbs
But if it's
Even just one
Some parts might be missing
Hahaha
That's all
So
What else
Oh yeah and then I
Do a lot of chores and stuff
Yeah
I have to make sure everything's kind of in order as well
A lot of things are taken care of
By manager and
The team
But you know there's still some stuff that I have to
Do
I definitely feel very blessed
To be in VLR
Because a lot of it is definitely
A
Just go and make
And create and do
And
And stream
It's not a bit too lenient to take
A limb for cheating
I'm so nice don't you think senpai?
I'm so nice that I give you so many chances
Just got to get stuff out there since the very beginning
Mmm
It's a lot of
Planning
So my weeks are
A month in advance
At least a month in advance
For my schedules
So
Um
Definitely because it's debut week
Things are
Um
Excuse me
Things are
Going
Are
On kind of accelerate
Accelerate
So it's a bit hectic
To just establish ourselves
It's just to establish ourselves
And
To kind of
Give
Senpai's and the fans
Like
A bit of taste of what
Our contents like
If something you're interested in
And then maybe
After the first month
I think after the first month
Well
I think
After the first month
I might be granted it sooner
I'm not sure
But alternative
Websites and stuff for streaming
Might be in the works
Because
Um
Yeah, so giving ourselves a month
To get used to
Our new
Our new schedule
Our new routine
And kind of establish ourselves
On
The
On the main
Platforms first
Hmm
So that's
Why
Things are kind of
A lot so far
I seem exhausted
It is definitely a lot
I will be slowing down
My schedule turns out I'm not slowing down that much
Apparently
I booked myself for like
Five streams
Next week
Four
When I said
I'm going to lower it down to three streams a week
That was a freaking lie
Blame myself
I had to double check my schedule
So I might do it
Later
Maybe it's slowly
Slowly
When will my next ASMR
Spring be
Maybe next month
I have to see
I have to see because I'm like booked up
I might be able to fit something in
Um
But I'm definitely having to fix some audio stuff
Because I know that my audio is
Really quiet and I have to fix that
Darn
Darn ending screen where I blew out
Senpai's
Ears out that was my bad
Ha ha
If you need a break
We understand
I probably need at least a break
Next week. This week I'm still good
I'm still ready
I got some maros
And some comments though
That said
Actually that
They were so relaxed for the ASMR
That
They didn't even wake up from
The loud jump scare
So I was really impressed
I was like oh okay
I guess I did a good job
It was my first time
I actually
Went to IC
IC is actually very
Very familiar with ASMR
So
IC's ASMR are
Definitely something to look forward to
I see so
So
So is a
Seasoned ASMRist
So
So I definitely look forward
To IC's
Stuff I had to go
To IC kind of
Like last night
And was like
What's cupping
And then she explained it to me quite well
And she gave me like a very good video
On like a cupping
Example
Because the ones that I was seeing
I felt like we're
We're not quite
Right?
I guess
So
Sorry if I woke you up
I was trying to
Research a little bit
Because there were some triggers
I wasn't familiar with
From SMPI
SMPI's requested
So I went and I was like what does this mean
Like I'm not doing it right
So yeah
I feel like there's some SMPI's
That definitely didn't like the cupping
I tried my best based off of the instructions
From SMPI's and chat
But I know that some people didn't like it
So I guess
I'll give a warning if I do do it
Because I know some people liked it
But I know there's a good handful of people that didn't either
So
I don't know if I had
Any like unique triggers
I didn't go to the store
And I bought like
Like the globes
Because
Strani said yes use the globes
The globes are like wonderful people love it
I
And I saw near the
Near the ice globes
I remember seeing like this cool gel mask
And I was like oh
Oh gee
I wonder if that's there but it wasn't at this
At this particular store
That I went to
So I went to a
Further store away
Of SMPI's
And thankfully I drove
I drove about 30 minutes
To go to another store
To see if they had
This gel mask I saw in stock
Because I remember touching it
As a sample before and I really liked it
Because it has like a bunch of little tiny gel balls
And it feels good
And I think it's
It sounds kind of nice
So I have them right here next to me
And so I brought
Lots of stuff too
I'm a bit of a giggler
Honestly if I'm trying to suppress my giggles
It just gets worse you know
I was trying to suppress
Uh
Suppress
Um
I was like
I just kept going
It was a cycle
It was a cycle because
You know when you try not to laugh
You laugh harder right
It was definitely one of those things
Where I was like oh
I can't stop
Because I'm trying to
To make it really quiet
And like soft
But because I'm stifling it
It's
Becoming stronger
And then
Senpai started laughing
And I couldn't help but laugh
Because I got so confused
I got confused about
What was it? Nibbling
I don't remember what it was
And I
I just went
Like a feral animal
It was biting sounds
I didn't know what it was doing
I didn't know what I was doing
So I was like oh
Gnoming sounds
What did gnoming sounds sound like?
Not that
Clearly
That's just
Yeah that was my mistake
Definitely something to think about it
Hahaha
I'm learning so
I'm learning so much because
Of
What I did was
I was listening to some J.P
J.P
ASMR VTubers
To see what they did
And
I was just really confused
The entire time
And so
When I was setting up my mic
I was like the girls were
Really quiet
I set up to be
Quiet
And then
I read
Like
And then I read
When you're whispering
You should do like a reel
And so I was like
Okay okay
I'll do a reel whisper
And instead I ended up doing a stage whisper
Because I was too quiet
I'll have to fix that up
I didn't want to
I didn't want to accidentally break
Senpai's ears
Especially if there were
Those who were
Who were already settled in
And like relaxing and about to sleep
To break any
Any
Any ears from me
Messing around with the audio
Who was I watching
I wasn't
I'm aware of
I'm aware of them
Since I
Had some maro suggesting
To check them out
So I'm aware of them
Who did I watch
I was watching
Petra
Cool
I was watching Petra's
ASMRs
And I thought
Petra's audios
Were kind of
Kind of more quiet
So I decided to go with more quiet
And I matched and I did some tests before stream
So I matched
The audio and how it jumped
In OBS
Her audios
The regular volume
With my audios and they matched
And I was like okay, we're good
And turned out they don't match on stream
So that sucked
So I
Kind of copied Petra
Sorry
I suck
Yeah, I'm sorry
I copied Petra a little bit
Because I was like okay, well Petra did this stuff
And I looked at some other
ASMR tubers
Who I don't remember, but I definitely referenced
A lot of Petra's stuff
Inspired, yeah
How dare you, yeah
When I say stole
It's more like matching audio
Matching types of audio
And seeing
The audio levels were
I don't really mean that I'm stealing
Her ideas or
Her triggers
It's more like
Seeing
What the volume was like
And what the pacing was
And
How she would go between ears
And stuff
Things like that
Yeah, like watching
The gain and matching the volume
Yeah, so that's what I did
But turns out it was too quiet on stream
So I was like oh shit
Oh shit
And I didn't want to adjust it
In case I adjusted
I overcompensated
So I was really worried
About overcompensating
But yeah
What I ended up doing
Was kind of picking my own things
That I sort of liked
So I basically went to the store
Touched every single like
Products in there and I just picked the ones
That I liked the most or like I remembered
That it was in the store
And if it wasn't in that store
I just drove
Basically 30 minutes away to
To
To another store
And then
Drove 30 minutes back
Just to get like
Do you have a few products?
Because I was like oh well
I liked these sounds
Or I liked these sounds personally
So that's what I was using
And then I ended up
Doing a lot of
Sempai suggestions
And requests because I was just like
Oh I don't know it
Does the store sell slime?
I was thinking about slime
But I was
Hmm
I was a little worried
Because I wanted something
To be
Um
I wasn't sure
If slime
Was a reusable
Product
Does that make sense?
I didn't know if it was a reusable product
Because
And then I also
Thought about
The whole YouTube thing
The whole YouTube things taking down channels
Usually is
Yeah I don't know though
Because it's like in a container and I was worried
Like oh what if like slime dries out and stuff
I've never really
Played with slime before
Does that make sense? Yeah I've never
Played with slime
I've never had an interest in slime
I know my friends were like
Oh my gosh I love slime
Here's like a new one that's chocolate scented
Or something and I'm like
I don't get it
But yeah I was like
Oh maybe slime
Making the squishing sound might be good
But the gel
The gel here
The squishing sound for the gel
Is
Stuck between like its little
Fabrics
So I thought that made it
Made it more
Safe?
Sorry
I was gonna say have you thought of oil massage?
I thought about it
But then I was worried that I would
I would ruin the 3DL
Cause I was like
I don't put it directly on right?
Um
I don't think I put it directly on
So I haven't really figured that out yet
I also didn't want to make a mess
Because
There's like a lot of
I have a lot of stuff here
That I don't want to get dirty
Um I didn't I ended up not going
With earpicks I do have a Japanese earpick
Uh
Because everyone does it
So I wanted to
Sort of differentiate
My first ASMR3
Just a bit
Not too much
So I
I don't want
I didn't want to just
Do it
To do something
Very common I suppose
Because
In my opinion when some people do
Earpicks I did not like them
I remember watching some videos going
I
No I don't like them
So because I didn't like it myself
Like I like using earpicks on myself
I'm like oh this is relaxing but if like
An audio was doing it
I'm like
Maybe not me
Maybe not that
And I was like oh everyone kind of
Does earpicks
So
I kind of wanted to differentiate myself
I even got the globes
The globes
Uh
Was in a different shape
So I was hoping it would make like a different
Different sound compared to what's
Rather than globes
So the globes I
Have right now
The globes I have right now are
Um
Are the bopple
End so you know normally it'll be around
Circle
It was shaped of a moon
It was a shape of a moon
So I thought it would make a unique
Sound
Can I feel like the
The bubbling sound
Uh
Made
What lasted a bit longer
In these ones
Have you posed with them yet
That was the first thing I did
When I got home I was like
Moon prism power
Makeup
The first thing I did
When I opened them
That was the first thing I did
Regular orbs
Like the regular ice
Rollers uh on standby
In case
I wanted like a little bit of variety
So I do have some of that
I
Think my biggest problem was
I was worried if I placed
Down the
Items it would make a loud
You know hold on
Sound
So I was like
Oh shoot where did I put it
I just put it in my lap
Or well actually
I'm wearing kind of a hoodie
Right now because
I put it in my
In my hoodie pocket
Question mercy is it
Awkward to have viewers who are much older
Or younger than you are
Excuse me
Sorry I didn't take a sip in a while
Not
In particular
Um I do have to
Say that due to the nature
Of my company I would
Prefer
To be over 18
And if you are not over 18
This is not the stream for you
Or at least this is not the company
For you
I feel like a different company
Would
Suffice more
I don't
Have any particular differences
I don't feel
Anything in particular
Simply because
I don't know I've been an entertainer
And like
I've been an entertainer for so long
That like
You know if it's an audience of
All ages it just happens right
So like
In plays
In plays and stuff
Sometimes
Kids and people of all ages
Go to play
And so sometimes
You'll see like an old couple
Will come in and watch a play
Maybe the play is meant for like
Older teens
And you'll see like an old couple
Old couple come
And watch the play
That you're performing
And I feel like
As an entertainer age doesn't really matter
Who your audience is as long as they're entertaining
So if you are on the older side
I don't mind
Mostly because
I'm used to it
It's hard to say
It may sound strange
Yeah maybe it's not like hard to say
But it sounds strange
I'm having a wide range
Of
People watching me
In different formats
So in different mediums
So I've had people of all ages
Watch me
In movies
I've had people of all ages
Watch me in stage plays
Watch me in like
You know like even like
Radio plays and stuff
So it's not something
That I think about
Too
Often
I don't think about age as like a restriction
Except for you know being in this company
Please be over 18
So
So things like that
So yeah
Anyone all ages are welcome
Except for under 18 you're not welcomed
Well maybe not
Not until you hit 18
Then
You're not ready for it yet
I'm trying to say this very nicely
What if I'm zero
Well
You're a very smart baby
And I think you need to be
You're too
You have too much
Linguist for a zero
You're old baby
And I think that
Maybe you're possessed
And that I would bring you to a priest
To be exercised
Hahaha
Sounds like an Amy problem
I know Amy's old
Old enough
What if I'm already at wizard's age
Like what
Like 30 30
You become a wizard
When you're like a virgin till you're 30 right
Why does that matter
Of course you're welcomed
Did I just reveal Amy's lollipop
No
No no
Amy's
Amy's legal
You know what
Fuck off, fuck off with that question
Screw you
Mods cussed off their testicles
Mods, odia, obliterate
Just kidding
Just get rid of that message
Hahaha
I'm just saying that
Uh yeah
To legally be a part of the lore
You must be above the age of 18
So 18 in human years
So both Amy and Icy
Meet that threshold
Or exceed it
Or not, I don't know
I don't actually know
I don't know how old Icy is
Really, but you know
By the power of strongy
Strongy had magical
Magical siren powers
And was able to tell
Be like yeah yeah yeah
Okay, you're in
So they cleared
They cleared the bar
Icy is, Icy is a polar bear
And uh
I don't know
And Amy is
Like
Basically an immortal, I guess
So I don't know
What, Amy's ages
And
Basically it's all
You know, it's all like
Everyone is at least of age
Within human years
And therefore can pay their taxes
Her age was question mark that day
If you, yeah, I don't freaking know
If I don't know
Just uh, if you're gonna ask ages
You should ask them, not me
We literally just talk about cats
And maybe we talk about our feelings
And we talk about like
You know, girly stuff
Old enough to drink, smile
Old enough to pay taxes
Who's dead
What's that
I'm about manly stuff
We leave that to
To...to you guys
I thought you guys talked about
Some demons' astronauties
Yeah, that's the plan in the future
Yeah, we talk about like
You know
Sacrifices
at the daily, at the yearly violor ritual.
Do you ever take the scissors out of your hair? Just curious.
Yeah, I do. I just think they look cool.
So they're there. They're there.
Are they functional?
Well, if they functioned completely, my ponytail would be chopped off.
So they sort of work. See, look, hold on. Let me, like, bounce a little bit.
And you can see that, like, they mostly work.
They are on a little pivot point, and they do move around,
but, like, I design them so that they don't fully cut my hair because...
I don't know. I feel like Senpai likes my ponytail, right?
Hard to tell. Can you zoom out a bit when you bounce?
You can't catch me with that.
I was, I was, we're, we're trying to go for monetization,
so I was instructed not to show a lot of skin.
Good, good try. Good try.
That's why the girls have been extra careful.
The girls have been extra careful recently.
I don't know.
Just kidding.
Because we don't want to get bonked.
It's already hard enough to try to get monetization,
so we don't want to get bonked.
Did you see Azura's bread? Yeah, I saw her bread.
I was like, oh, man, I want some toast now.
All milk toast sounds good, right?
I love the big bow. I wish we could see it bounce more, not until everything's safe
and sound. Everything's safe and sound, and then we we still might play it safe for
a little while.
Who's your favorite out of the girls? I love everyone, but if I have to be like, you know,
I love, I love, I love, I love, I love, I love, I love, I love everyone, but in particular,
I feel like I see I want to snuggle a lot more. And she just hits my, my must protect,
you know, feelings. But like, um, but like, I love all the girls equally. I love all the
girls equally. But if I had to pick like someone who I would like, love on more, I
guess it would be Icy. Who do you love more? Icy or Senpai Senpai? Not even, not even
a question. I love my Senpai more. But that being said, I love my Senpai more, but I will
cut a Senpai down if they ever hurt any of the girls. If you hurt their feelings, if
you try to, try to make them cry, I will. Does that make sense? I, I will show tough
love to Senpai. I will show tough love to Senpai. What if I'm sparring with them? If
it's like a mutual agreement that you two are sparring, yes, sure, it's fine, but if
like, you know, you decide to do something a little mean, a little mean, a little cruel,
I definitely do not like that. I definitely would not like that. If, if like, you know,
if you start comparing someone, like, I, I don't like this particular thing is like
if someone says, oh, like so and so is better than so and so, I will, we all are very charming
in our own ways. And so, you know, some of the girls, including me, especially me, will
get hurt if someone says things like that. And I'm sure the other girls would also feel
the same way. And be very protective of each other. Well, I see it so much better than
mercy die. Thank you, mods. Can we bully you in soup? Can we bully with super chat? Of
course, like playful bullying is fine. Playful bullying is fine. But, you know, like real
bullying, like you're trying to hurt us, you're trying to be malicious, you're trying to be
rude. I do not appreciate that. And that's probably just not even like somebody who's
not even a senpai, you know, teasing. Okay, of course teasing. Okay, it's playful. Your
skirt's cute. I want to see it. Hi. No. So yeah. So yeah, senpai would never hurt their
koi and a senpai wouldn't hurt my gen mates either. So yeah, that's my thing. I'm very
protective of them. I know that due to what we do, there are some bad, bad players, bad
players who've been very rude. And I've been very, very angry and curt with some rude players.
So I don't, I don't appreciate, appreciate that. But otherwise, you know, anything's fine. I love
my girls a lot. You've already encountered rude players, of course. Sometimes they hurt a lot,
like the comments they make, sometimes they hurt a lot. You know, usually it's waters off a duck's
back, but sometimes they hurt. And other times I will just be like, fuck this motherfucker.
You guys get nasty marshmallows all the time. All the time. I think the only one who
you have to grow tough getting in the sliding line of work, of course, I know that. But there's
some days where, you know, you're not that tough, you know, you're a little bit more sensitive that
day. And, and, you know, the mean things hurt a little bit more.
So like all of us have, have gotten hate in some form, comments, morals, whatever.
And we have each other, though, we talk about it, we talk about it, and we're like, oh, you know, if,
for example, I told my gen mates, I was like, oh, there's this comment so-and-so
that someone made and it really hurt my feelings. And, you know, we, we go, oh,
go screw that guy. They go screw that guy. You are this and this and you're beautiful. And,
you know, you are great. And mommy, mommy has to reassure me all the time, too.
Mommy, mommy always, always, she's always willing to, like, repeat, repeat the love,
right? Repeat the love over and over again.
Yeah, mommy has definitely seen some nasty comments. I've seen nasty comments before,
but I guess, you know, I'm, I still have, I still have a bit of feelings, I'm still kind of new,
I'm still adjusting. So some, some comments hurt, but then some, I'm just like, yeah, you know what,
screw you. But yeah, definitely, I get very protective of the, the girls. So if someone,
someone purposely tries to, like, hurt them or make things very, like, scary for them, I will
fucking, like, I will find your IP address. I will find your IP address. I will, I will find your
mother. I will find your mother. I will send her a message. You know, that kind of thing.
But most likely the company will take care of it. VLR will take care of it.
VLR takes care of everything. So don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. But, you know,
sometimes, you know, being what we do, there's a lot of rude players. And what I have to thank
my lovely mods to who, uh, definitely works hard to, to make sure that we don't see nasty comments
either. So they're very, very kind. Does it make up for it a bit when you hear about all the ways
you help us get through our days? Yeah, it does. But you know, sometimes, yeah, it does. And it's
a good reminder. It's a good reminder of, uh, that what we're doing is, is, makes people happy.
And of course, you know, there's so much love, but sometimes one comment, you're just like, oh,
that kind of hurt a lot. But most comments, honestly, most comments are, are, like, if I have
to say, like, of all comments, about 99% of them is, fuck you, blocked. But like, maybe a vacation
of 1%, you're like, oh, okay, that one kind of hurt. That one kind of hurt. But like, um, most of the
time it's, it's, uh, it's, yeah, fuck you, whatever. Fuck you, whatever. Go back to school, kid. I don't
know. Is this, is it summer break already? Go back to school. You're too young for this.
Stroni seems to have nerves of steel. I'm sure Stroni has her moments too.
I'm sure Stroni also has her moments. She doesn't really show it, but she probably has her moments
too. After all, we're all, we're all like, you know, we're all, we're all feeling, we're all feeling beings.
Honestly, actually, I notice, I notice if it's like spring break or summer break or something,
uh, even, even when, uh, before I got into VLR, like spring break and like summer break would be like
the mass of like little, little twerps, little, little trolls trying to, trying to get, get,
get out, uh, get at you. So I just ignore. Well, it's just a time, but sometimes, I don't know,
some, some, some things are like, oh shit, that kind of hurt. Oh well.
Mercy, if you weren't in a fighting game, what would your intro call be? Screen for Mercy? Probably.
It's my tagline. It's my tagline. Wow, what are you gonna expect? It's my tagline.
So yeah, I'm just like, oh, whatever, you know, it might hurt. Today, uh, I think I'm very moody
today though. I think it was a mix of being overwhelmed by the fast growth, fast growth, uh, and the,
and the, um, and the, and the imposter syndrome that like today was something that was like
particularly like, oh, wow, okay. Oh, but when I started playing the game and bantering with
some pies, I felt much better. What would your victory line be? I'll be it.
Are you playing, nervously playing with a pen right now?
No.
No. No, why would you say that?
Oh, I didn't realize I was peeking.
And that was the box cutter. It was the, it was the box cutter. Actually, it was right there.
So I was nervously kind of playing with the box cutter. I was nervously playing with it because
I was like, oh, I was nervous about it because, you know, thinking about, I'm like, oh, I don't,
our growth was pretty fast and I, I run imposter syndrome right now and I'm full of emotions and,
but I'm still like super thankful to be here, but I'm also very, very, uh,
I'm very thankful to be here and I'm very happy, but I'm also just like overwhelmed.
I'm overwhelmed. Uh-huh. What was the most nervous situation you've ever been in?
Um, debut.
Uh-huh.
Honestly, before debut, I was curious and you blew all my expectations away as someone who
never understood the yandere. Thank you. Thank you, Senpai.
I know I'm more on the dare side of yandere.
You did say you could barely walk because your legs were shaking so much. I stood up
and then I collapsed onto the floor because my legs were jelly after, after debut.
Um, yeah, 1 to 10, how embarrassed were you to post the, the alt, alt audio?
Um, 200, 200% maybe.
You don't vomit before? I didn't vomit, but I didn't have to go to IDO meetings
a lot because I was so nervous.
Uh, I used to vomit when I was super nervous and stressed. I used to vomit.
Uh, I don't know if I told the story or if I told the girls, if I told the girls this, but
um, the first time I had my, my uh,
my, my driver's license, I threw up in the car,
in the testing car several times.
And then when I went back for the, the advanced license, it was the same, uh, driving tester
person. And they were like, oh my gosh, vomit girl, welcome back.
Did you pass? Not the first time. I had to come back the next day because I, I was too nervous.
Uh, yeah, um, I got my license when I was like 16. And then so when I went back,
when I went back for my, my license for my, my advanced license, uh,
I was round 18. So the fact that it was the same guy and he remembered me after that long, I was like,
look, oh my god, vomit girl, welcome back. I would expect, oh, this is around the time that you
would come back for the, the license, right? I was like,
not the next name that you want.
It's like vomit girl. You're not going to vomit again, are you?
Did you at least do it outside the car? No.
Oh, he tricked me though. He tricked me because he was like, okay, we're going to just do,
tell me at least there was a bag. Uh, I threw up
at the testing place, uh, before. So I threw up a lot in the toilet and then I
brought a bag with me and I threw up in the bag. Yeah.
No, no, no, it didn't get like any, anywhere. It's just, yeah.
It didn't, I didn't hit the instructor. I didn't hit the instructor.
It was in a bag, but it was like, you know, something that I had to, had to grab,
you know, but just happened. So, um, it just happened.
The driving instructor tricked me though, tricked me. I was like, okay, we're just,
we're going to just go through the route. We're going through the route that we're going to do,
that we're going to do, just relax. It's not the real task. We're just going to,
to go through the, um, you know, go through the route to familiarize yourself with it.
You know, we went through the route and he said, your path, you passed. And I was like,
you motherfucker.
So, yeah, I didn't vomit cause of
yeah. It's like you motherfucker. Thank you. And then I got my license. Yeah.
So now you can run over your Senpai if he tries to escape.
I don't even need to run over Senpai if he tries to escape.
Do you guys, does my Senpai think he was just like, oh gosh, he's coming back?
I should prepare for this. Or maybe he was just, or maybe the instructor was like, oh,
well, this is going to happen probably more times than this, this one. So we're going to have to
plan around it. I'm probably, honestly, I was probably,
I was probably a learning experience for that driving instructor. Cause I barfed.
I barfed and then, and then I was like, oh man. So yeah, now, and I'm a decent driver.
For free, I barfed for free. No, it was the cost of my sanity.
In all fairness, I could probably run on eight feet if I had to escape. My knees
aren't what they used to. Of course not. They're not what they're used to after I hit them several
times when they'll last escape.
I should have been main out of bag. Oh my gosh, Senpai. You're kind of freaky.
You're kind of freaky and I don't know how to feel about that.
I don't know how to feel about that.
Honestly, so many of your stories involve barfing that could be called the vomit girl
veiler. No, I don't want that. I don't want that title.
I don't want that title. I never realized how many, how many barf, barf stories I had.
Oh man, you're right. Oh, I gave you two barf stories.
No, I don't want that title.
I definitely do not want that title.
At least it wasn't three barf stories. I can't think of another one. These are the only two
stories that I currently remember that involve vomit in some way.
Oh no, except for, no, I had three stories. You're right. I told you three stories.
All right, about the one time where the reason why I don't drink anymore.
All right, that story. Oh, shit.
Oh, shit. That was the story I told, told on, told what day, shit.
Oh, you're right, Senpai. Oh no.
No, I don't want to be the barf girl or the barf tuber.
No, stop it, Senpai, please. Please, Senpai, stop it. I got nervous and I have allergies and
and and I have motion sickness.
I don't, oh, is there any other stories?
Oh, it's mostly involving with my allergies, my, um,
oh, don't call me Mercy, my barf, stop it.
At least you showered after you barfed, right? Did I?
I don't remember. I just remember that part.
No, it was like, that was, that was years ago. How am I going to remember that part?
I don't remember. I remember there were some days where I had such a bad allergic reaction.
I just had to go to sleep. I had to sleep on my side.
At the hospital because, because of that. Just remember it, forehead. I can't remember. I have,
do you remember? Do you remember what you did and so and so years ago, all the details?
Shut the fuck up. You're lying to me. You're lying to me. Get the shock collar.
Shock collar.
Ugh.
Honestly, I'm just saying, I'm just saying, I don't, I don't particularly want
to be known as the barf vtuber. I haven't barfed on stream yet.
So I would rather not. I barfed off stream. Oh shit. No, you're right. I had, oh shit,
you're right. What I told, told senpai's about, about I got sick on the debut 2.0. That's,
oh shit. That's a fourth story. You're right. Oh no.
No, I'm starting to remember all the stories I'm telling senpai's.
Yet, I can't tell the future, okay?
It's, I'm, I'm kind of dumb.
I'm kind of dumb, man.
Ugh. The slave was not going to go away, is it? I'm so upset now. I'm, I'm,
I'm so upset. I, I, I have many feelings right now.
No, no, please, no, no, no, no, no, no. No, you know what?
Conversation over. I don't like this. I don't like, I don't like the direction. I don't like how
right senpai is right now. I am, I don't like it. I don't like it right now.
Ugh.
Stomach, stomach, stop. Cease, cease and assist.
I have a sensitive stomach, okay? I just have a lot of,
Ugh.
New topic quick, new topic quick. Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
Senpai, I love you.
What are you listening to in the car?
Silence? The road?
I did have the,
yeah, dichotomy, dichotomy is the word of the day.
Now I like to work in silence. Like I said, senpai, I don't really listen to music that much.
I did listen to when, uh, I remember my car had a CD stuck in it because I had,
um,
I had, I had, uh, what was the album? Like,
I was going on a road trip and what was the album?
Daft Punk's Interstellar 555, like the album, the album that was, uh,
that was like associated with that, that one.
That one, I, I had, it was stuck. It was stuck in my car, so I just listened to it every time I trove.
I had it because, uh, there was like a road trip with me and my gal pals because we were going,
going to like, uh, some place, another town over for something I can't remember.
So, no, they're like, oh yeah, just put on some music, you know? Uh, and I was like, oh, okay,
yeah, sure. And so I, I picked up this, uh, the album. I got it from Japan, uh, from my, uh,
from a music, music and books, use music and bookstore.
Cole High, is this another fire story? No!
It just, it was just stuck in there. I couldn't take it out. There was something wrong with the,
with the CD player thing and it just wouldn't leave.
Oh, it was a book off? No, it was a,
uh, it was a, like, uh, it was, it was a local shop that was run by like, uh, this old lady and her,
and her son. Uh, but it was mostly the old lady that was there and it was, it was like,
just, uh, kind of like a little mom and pop shop.
Um, my Spotify playlist is probably just like OSTs. I've been listening to the .hack OST a
lot, like the anime one. That one's really good. Cole High doesn't know how to use a CD player.
No, it was like legitimately broken, legitimately broken. I had to bring it back into the shop
and be like, okay, my CD is stuck in there. By the way, can I get it out? And I said,
ah, shit. Yeah, well, we'll work on that too.
Oh, so you do listen to OSTs? Sometimes. I like working in silence a lot, but if I'm
trying to evoke a mood, I will, I will probably listen to an OST.
I will probably listen to the OST. So do you listen to any Nikkei OSTs? Uh, when I play Nikkei,
the, the only time I ever listen to the Nikkei OST is with a Nikkei.
So you don't like instrumentals? Uh,
no, my favorite song in, in, um, my favorite piece in the .hack OST is, uh, what was it called?
I can't remember. I can't remember the rest of the lyrics. I would remember it definitely if it was
You know.
I can't remember what it was. Is it Aura?
Oh, the world. It was called... anyway, I don't remember.
Maybe?
I can't remember. I can't remember.
It might be Aura, so yeah. That's the one I liked.
Oh, the...
But it does not mean a thing to me.
Something like that.
And Inuyasha had some great songs too.
Yeah, I remember Inuyasha.
I want to change the world.
Something something can't remember the lyrics.
That song was stuck in copyright hell.
During the ABU, you said you wanted to record some original songs.
Any hints you can give about what you've written?
Where's my phone?
Yeah, I listened to the near OST as well.
No.
It's kind of embarrassing.
But yeah, I definitely love Inuyasha. Oh my gosh!
Azura loves Inuyasha too, right?
I think we both have our weeb awakening with Inuyasha.
I remember loving Inuyasha.
I had all the DVDs until someone stole it.
What was it? I can't remember some of the lyrics.
Yeah.
Someone stole it? Yeah!
My entire DVD collection!
I was so upset!
I was so upset I cried.
I cried. I cried for days.
And I knew exactly who fucking stole it.
I know who stole it.
And that little son of a... son of a bitch...
Moved the next day!
I knew it was that little shit stain!
How did someone steal your entire DVD collection?
Did I just stole it?
It was when I was really young.
So it was this kid.
And I definitely know he fucking stole it.
Because he visited the house that day.
And I was like...
Oh yeah! I'm moving! Let's hang out!
And the next day my entire collection was gone!
That little fucking shit stain.
I'll fucking kill that little bitch.
What?
I didn't realize it was gone until like that little...
Snake...
Was gone.
Until that little snake was gone.
And then ever since then I was just like...
I don't trust anyone with my things.
Parents did nothing?
Oh they tried!
But that little shit stain moved someplace we didn't know.
Where they moved, you know?
They were just gone.
Yeah, they were gone.
Like how am I supposed to know?
Right?
So I was really upset.
I had all the movies.
I had all of it.
I was so upset.
My sister bought me all the movies.
And it wasn't cheap.
Those DVDs weren't cheap.
So I dealt with a lot of shit.
I dealt with a lot of shit.
Like I dealt with a lot of shit as a kid so I'm really pissed.
I'm mad thinking about it all over again!
I'm getting...
I'm really upset now.
If you're on maybe start the collection again.
I don't...
I don't feel like starting the collection again.
I'm just mad.
In general, they had like...
Okay, like...
The DVDs I had would have like the limited edition cards.
And like they're the special coin.
That was so cool, like the special memento coin.
I don't sell those fucking shit anymore.
That was just really upsetting.
So upsetting.
So upsetting to this day.
If I ever find that fucking little kid again,
I'll fucking like curb stomp that little shit.
That little shit's probably an adult now.
Curb stomp, stomp him against them, whatever.
Did you like this point? No!
No, I didn't!
No, he just came by and said,
Yeah, I'm moving because we used to play
all together as a neighborhood kid.
Right?
Like all the kids in the neighborhood would just play together
and then this kid was going through
to every single fucking person's house
and was like, oh yeah, I just want to hang out a bit
because I'm moving, blah blah blah.
That little shit probably took something from everyone.
I'm still mad thinking about it.
Probably still from fucking everyone.
I know, I know some of, I know there was a family
in my neighborhood that got banned
in my neighborhood that got banned from everyone's frickin' house.
Oh, I'm still mad. I'm still mad. There's this, uh...
So, there's a house, uh...
And these kids were not exactly the greatest, and, uh...
Oh, they were- they reached an all- all time low one time when they- when for some reason, uh, Papa Mercy was like,
Okay, you know, maybe they've changed.
Maybe they've changed. Let's invite them to your birthday, and I said,
Fuck no, and then he did it anyways, and they stole my birthday presents.
It's like, fuck those kids, too.
Not like, you know, but like, I- I'd fucking, like, curb-stop them.
And... okay.
And the worst part was that...
We went to the parents.
Listen, listen. We went to the parents. Like, my mama and papa went to the parents.
And... was like, hey, your kids, they stole the presents.
And, you know, clearly they're playing with the fucking presents.
Um, you know what the audacity of the fucking parents did? They said, oh, we bought it. We bought it for them.
I was so pissed.
Mmm, I- mmm.
I think the police were called and everything, and like, the police were like,
Okay, we can't do anything about it, because you can't prove that it was like yours or something, and I was like,
Ah, your son.
And so, and so, like, I know that family is like banned completely. They are shunned in the neighborhood.
I was so upset. I was so upset.
Ugh.
I was so upset. Like, honestly, they were completely shunned. They stole- they stole from everyone.
They stole from everyone. When police got involved, like, they're like, oh, you can't prove that they did it, right? And I'm like,
The fuck you mean? I can't fucking prove it.
They still live in the neighborhood. I glare at them every once in a while.
Oh no, that was a different family. Gosh, I hate this. I hate that it was like two different families.
I
Actually, ever since then, I'm not going to lie. I had a really bad rebellious streak. Like, I was pretty much a delinquent.
Yeah, like, they would- I have like, you know, cameras and stuff now.
But I would never forgive them. I won't ever forgive them. Nothing has fucking changed.
Wait, nothing has changed? Are you talking about my delinquent self?
I think I calmed down quite a bit. I give- I give people more chances than not.
I did have a very violent streak growing up.
I did, I did, but I think I'm quite- I think I'm- I'm more lenient now, Senpai. You should be- you should be grateful for that.
Like, I was-
I was pretty ruthless back then. Pretty ruthless.
How many people did you beat up?
Let's skip that question. Let's skip that question.
Let's skip that question.
I will say that one time, when I was doing- I was doing an exam, uh-
Somebody asked me for my name. Like, the person who sat next to me
said, um, my name. And I said my name, and they said, from- from- from so-and-so
School, and I said, huh? How do you know me? And they moved four- four fucking seats away from me. Okay?
Let's just say- let's just say that- that's enough. That's enough, okay?
Okay?
So, uh, I didn't know them. I didn't know them, but they said so-
Mercy? Mercy from so-and-so School?
Yeah?
Four seats away!
Um, what do you mean? Any advice? I was- I was very-
Honestly, I was very ruthless. I was very ruthless. I did things that I feel very- a lot of shame for.
Maybe it was scared of you to throw up on him. Oh, no. No, I didn't have that reputation.
Now I did. Thanks to this stream.
Um.
I don't think I'm personally any, uh, I don't think personally I have, like, uh, an aura of someone who's, like, violent.
But, uh, I definitely have a little bit- I- I did make a bit of a name for myself in my youth.
Because I was definitely very much delinquent. Like, yeah.
I'm not violent.
I don't have a violent aura.
I don't! I don't! I've calmed down quite a bit, Senpai. So Senpai should be thankful. I've calmed down quite a bit.
I've- I've definitely calmed down quite a bit, but I- I definitely had a delinquent day. Like,
like, thinking like the kind of, like, you know, think, like, typical Japanese, like, delinquent. Think about it like that.
Something like that.
I've changed quite a bit since then. I've definitely apologized quite a bit for back then.
Yeah.
What's the worst thing you've done? I don't want to say. I don't want to say what's the worst thing I've done.
That is, uh, nope. No, we're not gonna answer that.
I'm not gonna answer that.
Let's just say-
Let's just say that, um, it was-
No, no. Actually, I'm not even gonna hint to what it was.
Yeah, it was just Jay walking.
There are definitely things that will remind me of that moment, so I just go-
So, yeah, I feel- I feel quite a bit ashamed about that.
Oh, yeah. The crosswalk was never the same. Nope, it wasn't.
Yeah, I feel like you definitely had to put things in the past.
Yeah, yeah, I feel like that, too. That's why I'm just like, I don't want to talk about it.
I don't want to talk about it because, um-
I don't want- I'm moving on from that.
I'm moving on from that.
No, it is not something that I would probably be put to jail for.
No, no, no, no, no. Nothing- nothing that- that- that bad.
It's nothing that bad.
And nothing like, you know-
Um-
Nothing that's like FBI would be like, oh, okay, we can't find my outlawner.
But it wasn't bad morally, but it was- it would have definitely-
It would have definitely-
Let's just say it- it definitely, uh, was- was put on a record.
It was- was put on a record.
In my youth.
Yeah, let's move on.
Let's move on. Fuck it.
If there was a place I could talk about it, it would be with my closest peers.
And unfortunately, I want my best face for my senpai.
My best face for my senpais.
So, yeah. Yeah, sorry to- to like, just cut that off right there.
Sorry to cut that conversation off right there.
Like, I just- I just don't want to think about it.
Um-
Now I'm thinking about it.
Now I'm in a bad mood.
You know what?
Let's-
Let's just take the day off right now.
I think- I think- I think I streamed quite a- quite a bit.
I think I streamed quite a bit.
Diligence?
Diligence was yesterday's cool word.
This- this today's, uh, cool word as dichotomy.
Sorry, kahai. No, it's okay.
It's- it's- it's me.
It's me for like, uh, what do you call it?
It's me for like, lingering.
Lingering on it.
Stop calling me barf girl.
I just want senpais to know that I am-
I am the- the- a much different person than I was back then.
And I want to stay in this good position.
So I love you senpai.
I love you so much.
We'll see each other again tomorrow.
And, uh, is there anything else I need to say?
Like, subscribe, leave a comment.
I forgot to say that, like, the last few streams.
I remember.
I remember Manny sounds like, oh yeah, don't forget to-
don't forget to like, say that.
And I'm like, oh, okay.
All right.
Thank you senpais.
Oh, by the way, the story before?
Forgetty Beam.
It's now forgotten out of your memory and will not be brought up again.
Got it?
I love you senpai.
Okay.
Good night.
Scream for Mercy.
I hope this isn't as loud as last time.
Let's go. Bye.
Thank you.